improvisadas cremaciones masivas en
nueva delhi es el reflejo de la
devastadora crisis sanitaria en índia
cuando el país supera los 17 millones de
contagios de kobe 19 y cierra sumando
récords mundiales de fallecimientos más
de 2 mil cada día muchos creen que las
muertes se han minimizado subestimando
el costo humano de la segunda ola de la
pandemia si nunca ha estado en una
cremación el olor a muerte no lo
abandona nunca mi corazón se rompe por
todos mis amigos y familiares en delhi e
india- que están pasando por este
infierno india está reportando más de un
millón de casos positivos de coronavirus
cada tres días los epidemiólogos estiman
que los datos reales son mucho más
dramáticos la doble variante del
patógeno detectada en el país la
pasividad de las autoridades respecto a
las restricciones a finales de año y la
situación socioeconómica del segundo
país más poblado del mundo son algunas
de las causas que han llevado al colapso
sanitario del país cuyos frágiles
hospitales carecen de suministros para
hacer frente a la emergencia para
controlar la situación es muy importante
que a medida que vayan llegando los
nuevos casos tengamos tanto son más
pacientes recuperándose
cuando la demanda de oxígeno baje sólo
entonces se cubrirá la diferencia entre
la oferta y la demanda este lunes
mientras la nación espera la prometida
ayuda internacional el gobierno indio
ordenó a las fuerzas armadas que ayuden
a la lucha contra el virus
proporcionando oxígeno y médicos
militares a los abrumados hospitales
aire ferrocarril carretera y mar se está
moviendo cielo y tierra para superar los
desafíos planteados por esta ola de kobe
19 limpia también ha pedido a sus
ciudadanos que acudan a vacunarse sólo
una décima parte de los 1350 millones de
habitantes han recibido el suero contra
el coronavirus